this is swype on the show we're at one
of Europe's biggest climate change
events finding the green tech pioneers
of the future open wide I get a go on a
dentist drill but thankfully my patient
is a virtual one and get ready to rock
out with Lenny we've got guitar hero
live in our games review hello from the
climate kick innovation festival here as
bad this is where some of Europe's most
promising clean tech startups are
competing against each other the
technology they developed to help fight
climate change from bottles you can eat
the robots but clean let's take a look
now at some of their inventions is
Angela this edible water container could
mean the end of plastic bottles when
you're done with you who you can eat it
it's made from seaweed and it's
biodegradable there's a big demand for
renewable ideas to produce a low-carbon
economy and innovators are trying to
accelerate that shift and make it happen
faster if you look at the science of
climate change today it's clear that
we're heading in a very bad direction
indeed and we have to move fast and the
only thing which will allow us to move
fast is new technology essentially in
all the different fields whether we're
talking transportation lighting energy
distribution the whole works here's one
concept that could help produce the
impact of rising sea levels caltrop is
focused on building natural dams by
planting mangrove plants to catch and
collect river sediment coultrip is the
modular degradable system that we
planned parallel to the coastline even
in two levels if needed and then we put
the mangrove trees inside these modules
so it catches the sediment coming from
the river and then when it's not needed
anymore it degrades and builds into the
soil other innovations include this one
by Agri Lucien a kitchen system that can
grow vegetables and herbs without soil
and here's one aiming to reduce fuel
consumption and emissions the shipping
industry emits over 800
million tons of carbon dioxide each year
some of this is caused when slime algae
and barnacles attach to a vessel's hull
fleet cleaner has developed inspection
robots to remove this this idea is
already being used in Finland repack is
a returnable and reusable system for
online shopping and with me is the man
behind it so tell me more about it when
you're shopping online firstly of course
choose your stuff that you're going to
get but then at the checkout you can
choose repack as you delivery packaging
and when you get your stuff all you do
with repack is fold it in the letter
size drop it into a post box anywhere in
the world comes back free of charge and
then when this is coming back to us we
are going to reuse it and you are
rewarded with a voucher for your next
online purchase these startups may have
commercial solutions to climate change
but they're working in a market where
techniques are experimental and many
innovations haven't been proven yet so
it can be difficult to get funds which
is why competitions with financial
incentives like climate kick are so
important Angela Barnes Sky News you're
watching swype still to come I get hands
on with the simulation kit helping train
dentist but first here's a roundup of
some of this week's other techniques
Apple's head of software has been
telling us how old-fashioned television
channels are Eddy Cue were speaking
around the launch of the new Apple TV
which lets viewers use voice commands to
choose what they watch we wanted to
bring to television in a way what we've
done with the phone and that is apps
things like Siri the touch interface and
so we really wanted to revolutionize how
you looked at your television the
witcher 3 wild hunt was the big winner
at this year's golden joystick awards
taking 5 gongs including ultimate game
of the year grand theft also picked up
for including best multiplayer for its
online version whilst the Toru owatta
Nintendo's late CEO who died in July was
honored with the Lifetime Achievement
Award
an all-in-one sleep companion for
children has launched on crowdfunding
site IndieGoGo raising over 21,000
pounds in 7 days as well as acting as a
night light Remy can track your child's
sleep and you can set it to wake up the
little ones when you're ready stick
around we've got the new assassins creed
coming up in our games review now about
that dentist drill action i mentioned
earlier this week i was lucky enough to
go inside one of the world's leading
dental schools to have a go on some
virtual reality kit helping trained
dentists and i got to have a chat with
one of the inventors to sew these your
3d glasses they give you a 3d view and
view of your new patients i need to wear
these to do some drilling on my poor
patient absolutely so grabbed a
handpiece under there that's it lifted
up absolutely perfect and then down here
you've got a foot pedal so if you press
down on that i need to start to spin up
there you go that's it there you go and
you see that brown area in the tooth so
that's the decayed material this patient
has not been looking after their teeth
properly so you need to remove as much
of that brown area as possible without
removing any of the healthy person am I
going to press down that's it so push
into it good this that makes me feel
sensitive and so you can feel that you
can feel the contact you're making
that's really important because what
we're using is a haptic device haptics
is the science of touch basically so
happy device gives you realistic force
feedback it's basically equivalent to
what a computer monitor gives you
visually this gives you that realistic
touch sensation I always get such
sensitive teeth when I'm at the dentist
so is this kind of training teaching
dental students how to determine that
pressure how forceful to be exactly it
gives you a lot more information you
would do using traditional methods for
example so you know exactly how hard
you're pressing you know how much real
feel you've removed
decayed material it gives you a lot of
metrics you couldn't normally get and
you see haptic technology being rolled
out news in other Kaiser surgery can we
practice brain surgery using this kind
of technology absolutely we've audion
developed this with King's College
London to do both dental drilling and
injection and we're crowdfunding now to
take this through to a commercial
product where we intend to roll out a
huge number of different surgical and
medical training procedures I think I've
really overdone it on this guys too what
do you think um I think we'll give you a
sleep loss this time that's pretty good
I wouldn't even give myself an F for
that now it's time for you to take
center stage and unleash some of that
musical talent you'll see what I mean in
just a moment here's Chris with our
games review Guitar Hero live it's been
a while since these sort of rhythm based
games have been around I haven't played
once his guitar hero too which was while
ago so for me coming back into guitar
has been quite a lot of fun I've changed
a controller up rather than just four
buttons along the top now six with free
above them free below which adds a new
sort of challenge to it and a lot of fun
there's a live element to it hence the
name to our hero live we're in front of
a live film crowd that will either like
cheer you are you doing right or just
completely boo you as you're doing
terribly it's no real in between you're
either the best thing ever or the worst
thing ever it's a little gimmicky but
it's kind of funny people watching you
but the best thing is i hero TV just
a-rolling mtv-style channel it just
keeps playing music videos and you can
play along to constantly and multiplayer
still a lot of fun I'm Lenny Kravitz
Saturn's Creed syndicate is the
continuation of a long series there's
one that comes out every year and for me
it's not really an evolution of the
series it's more a return to form the
last game unity was full of bugs and was
fine but not that great this one however
feels more like some of the older games
when I actually enjoyed them and had fun
with them he played two people Jacob and
Evie Frye in Victorian London so you get
to run around exploring Victorian London
one of my favorite things is you look
out on the river thames full of boats
just delivering goods everywhere and
there's someone who's very sad and into
history it's a lot of fun also I way
prefer playing a TV because she's got
with this cane with knives on it and all
sorts of crazy stuff but it's really fun
to play with so if you like say the
older Assassin's Creed games like
Assassin's Creed 2 this is a return to
that the beginner's guide is made by a
company called everything unlimited
limited which is a very funny name I
like it and they previously made the
Stanley parable and I say they this is
all pretty much made by one person this
game takes you on a little journey where
you turn on a desktop and there's a
bunch of unfinished sort of conceptual
games and the narrator sort of prompts
you blitz you think this playthrough
these little unfinished weird games and
try and get an idea about the person we
made the game so you click for employees
little weird abstract games it's sort of
an interesting insight into the
relationship between sort of the
consumer and the Creator because you get
well the narrator's talking to you get a
strong idea about this is sort of what
the person was like you got a weird
jaggedy sort of mindscape kind of games
you like person maybe wasn't in a good
place when they made this a little bit
of a game and you get a picture of a
person as the engine is pretty good
hey 05 it's the second jaunt by free for
free industries who are the new sort of
caretakers of the Halo franchise off the
bungee have moved on to other games and
it's a lot of fun I don't wanna give too
many spoilers for the main campaign but
you have Spartan Locke coming in who's a
new guide to the sort of halo sing and
he's hanging out with a bunch of old
people that you played like this but I
by Nathan Fillion in who was in Halo 3
ODST and they're all hanging out looking
for master chief who's on the run now
apparently go and spoil any because it's
really fun if you like halo you're gonna
like this it's got a lot of class at
halo moments the main thing for me
though but I really enjoyed was the war
zone multiplayer mode and it's kind of
just bundled everything into halo
multiplayer so you've got AI enemy teams
running around you've got a team of
other people that you're fighting
against you've got bosses you've got
objective to capture you've got vehicles
everywhere it's just everything and it
feels like they're just going to let
what's everything fun about haylor
markiplier let's just put it all in this
and have a ton of fun with it it's
definitely worth checking out it feels
like an evolution of first-person
shooter
that's it for this week take a look at
Sky News on mobile and iPad and find out
who has named Europe's best clean tech
startup at this event I'll see you next
week bye bye